cloudy skies overnight those are  sticking around through our thursday  morning you can see  just a little sun out there and because  of the clouds it's keeping a lot of heat  in the valley  temperatures are in the 90s this morning  but that doesn't give us much room at  all to cool off  before we start seeing those  temperatures going back up so 1 16  yesterday we'll see some clearing  through the day  but it's going to be hazy sunshine back  through those  90s in the morning hours right up to  triple digits at noon 106  yes it will be getting very hot by  lunchtime and then we're right back up  to 113 or 114  with hot hazy sunshine and again that  heat is just relentless